kenzo im süden ländlich konservativ
gottesfürchtig die republikaner stark
die impfquote schwach
in der uniklinik der hauptstadt little
rock macht sich randy fertig für den
täglichen kampf der feind heißt delta
und seine opfer machen es ihm zu leicht
eine extra schicht liegt randy heute ein
weil das personal vorne und hinten nicht
mehr reicht für die welle an
schwerkranken immer mehr schwangere auch
mehr jüngere und kinder
jerry yang bleibt ist oberschwester und
die intensivstation war noch nie in der
pandemie so voll wie jetzt sie möchte
uns etwas zeigen was ihr ganz wichtig
ist es ist nur ein kleiner zettel aber
er hat es in sich
eine umfrage auf unserer station hat
ergeben 15 cupid patienten sind
ungeimpft
zwei sind zwar geimpft haben aber ein
geschwächtes immunsystem
und ein kobe patient hat erst die erste
impfung
für mich heißt das doch lasst euch
erst wenn es dann um leben und tod geht
kommt die reue
drd erkennt die verzweifelten gespräche
nur zu gut könnt ihr mich impfen nein
jetzt ist es zu spät
jeder hier bereut es ist herzzerreißend
jeder patient hier ungeimpft und krank
bedeutet es ist schwer leute zu sehen in
der letzten woche ihres lebens und sie
wissen es war ihre entscheidung ihre
entscheidung hier zu sein in diesem raum
in diesem bett und sie wissen sie werden
es vielleicht nicht schaffen
dieser hat den ultimativen preis bezahlt
wir sind am krankenhaus mit ihm
verabredet seine frau christin zu hause
ist traumatisiert
bis vor kurzem waren sie eine glückliche
familie fünf kinder aktiv keine angst
vor kurve keine impfung dann kam delta
beide kämpften wochen lang um ihr leben
und christin war im sechsten monat
schwanger
ich dachte sie wird gesund aber es wurde
schlechter und schlechter ich habe mir
wirklich sorgen gemacht auch um unser
baby
dann hat das baby es einfach nicht
geschafft zu
wenig sauerstoff
an ging es nur noch um eine frau
was soll schon sein dachte er vorher ich
bin doch jung dachte vielleicht ist der
impfstoff gefährlicher als das virus
ich will einfach mehr daten sehen
der impfstoff war einfach zu neu
und das und weiß gar nicht wie man
glauben soll was irgendwie traurig ist
die impfrate liegt hier in den
republikanisch geprägten südstaaten nur
bei etwa 40 prozent deutlich niedriger
als im rest des landes
dr der klagt deswegen die politiker von
arkansas an die republikanische
regierung hat wie in anderen staaten
auch jedwede masken oder impfpflicht
verboten unsere politiker helfen uns
nicht verabschieden gesetze die es uns
schwer machen das richtige zu tun
die konservativen sind darüber gespalten
aber am rechten rand wird weiter
gezündelt medien prediger politiker
während die infektionszahlen in ihren
staaten explodieren
[Applaus]
hier in florida wird es keinerlei
beschränkungen und keine masken pflicht
geben
pt 1 it's the end delta ist und bleibt
quatsch
in meine kirche kommt ihr nicht mit
maske
lasst euch nicht impfen
wir sind mitten in einer moralischen
park wenn neuer arbeitgeber euch zu
einer impfung verpflichtet die ihr nicht
braucht und mit dem blassen droht dann
ist unser rat wehrt euch droht mit
klagen macht nicht mit ihr seid
amerikaner ihr müsst das nicht
viele sind jetzt total verunsichert in
ihrer kleinen apotheke am rande von
little rock kämpft corrie gordon dagegen
an jeder kann hier reinkommen und sich
impfen lassen wie überall in den usa
eine impfung kriegt man ebenso leicht
wie ein hustenbonbon
aus angst vor delta kommen jetzt täglich
mehr
von rocker hatte letztes jahr selber
cupid und gerade erst starb eine gute
freundin das war der letzte auslöser
aber lang war sie gegen die impfung war
misstrauisch
der impfstoff kam so schnell ich habe
immer gesagt das ist doch ein versuch
ein test am ende fangen wir noch alle an
zu bellen oder so
ich habe freunde und geliebte menschen
an cupid verloren erst letzte woche an
die delta variante da habe ich dann
gemerkt okay jetzt wird's ernst
sie wollen endlich wieder sorglos in die
schule gehen können er ohne angst seine
pakete ausliefern
für kate ist es ein trost dass sich
jetzt mehr leute impfen lassen er glaubt
fest daran dass der tod seines babys
nicht sinnlos war wenn seine geschichte
dazu beiträgt